SHARAD JONES: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
Today's topic, we're going to
be talking about cloud security.
And then going to have
a brief discussion
at the end on data ethics.
But I think it should
be a fun lecture.
At least, this topic
excited me to do research on
and to talk about.
I mean, it's something
that impacts everyday life,
whether you realize it or not.
And honestly, it's
a great career path.
If you are ever interested
in just security in general,
we actually have some great
programs in just general purpose
IT security, computer security.
But I also think in the
context of the cloud,
there's some interesting
applications and also
some interesting tools
to mitigate these risks.
But we'll talk about that.
We'll talk about those
vulnerabilities and some
of the solutions to them.
So let's just jump
right into it.
And I'll slide out of the
way then to the bottom right.
Perfect.
So I want to start off
by doing something here
that actually will
be your unit project
as well for this section.
I hope it's a fun unit project.
But right now, I have
a code on the screen,
so feel free to pause it,
rewind, wait here and come back
to it.
But I want to know if
you can crack this code.
I'm not going to tell you
anything else regarding it.
You'll get information
if you crack it better--
or is the best I can say.
But either way, this is an idea.
This is what we
are talking about,
at least when we start with
this concept of encryption.
We've already dabbled
in it a bit, right?
We'll talk about these
key pair situations
we've done, where every time
we've launched an EC2 instance,
we've had to add a key pair
and what that even means.
But a big part of that is
this idea of encryption.
So I'll leave it there--
and then talk about
why do we even
need to encrypt information.
So think about all the data that
we have stored in the cloud, all
that information, very,
very sensitive information.
We've even talked about that
there exists the government
cloud for confidential and
unclassified information.
There's also a top
secret cloud in AWS
for top secret information.
And you can imagine
that is very critical.
I mean, I think the
definition of top secret
is something that could
cause grave danger
to national security.
So you could imagine
it's pretty critical
to ensure that that
information can't be read
except by the relevant parties.
And so what would happen if
someone gained access to it?
I mean, the world's your oyster.
You can think about all
the bad scenarios that
can happen if somebody were
able to gain access to not just
your data, but maybe even
the AWS servers entirely,
and if that information
wasn't encrypted, what they
could do with that information.
So encryption really gives
us this tool, this mechanism
for ensuring that only
those with the secret key,
ignoring that they need
to access the accounts
and be on the right IP
address and all that,
but assuming they've gotten
through all those layers,
our last layer of
defense here is
that we want to ensure
that only those people that
have that secret key
can decrypt our data.
They're the only ones that can
decrypt the information, which
is great for us, right?
Because, again, if we download
the secret key onto our machine
and we have that
available, then great.
Everything looks normal to us.
We don't even see
any sort of issues.
There's no hiccup in decrypting.
But if you don't have
that, you should just
see a bunch of nonsense, right?
Probably even more nonsense
than what this looks like.
If it gives you a hint to this,
you're missing information here.
This is not a good encryption
scheme for a couple of reasons.
But for one is it's
annoying to decrypt.
If you don't have some
sort of information
as the party of interest that
I want to give the message to,
well, then you can't
do anything with it.
You just see a matrix
of numbers here.
And so I need to have some way
for you to easily decrypt it.
But then also notice
here, too, that there's
a lot of repeating
patterns and whatnot that
might be a hint of how you
can go about solving this.
But either way,
that's definitely
not something you want
to do because there's
a lot of classic
techniques to break this.
So somebody wants to take
the time and explore this,
I welcome you to.
And then I can't wait
till you get down
the rabbit hole of
cryptography and code breaking
and all that good stuff
because it'll eat up
a couple of months of
your life because it's
such an interesting topic.
But yeah, so moving
on from there,
this is what we've been
dealing with up to this point.
We have this idea of a
public key and a private key.
Whenever we set up our EC2
instance, we have to have those.
And so the way
that roughly works
is there exists some
pseudorandom number generator.
So that's what RNG stands for.
And the reason I
say pseudo RNG is
because, whether you are
aware of this or not,
there doesn't really
exist a true random number
generator on our computers.
If I go to Google right now and
type in, give me a random number
1 through 10, it'll give me
something that seems random,
but that's the exact point--
is we're basically creating--
we use formulas on the back-end
equations that seem to replicate
randomness to some extent
in that--
for example, let's say,
we did the 1 through 10,
we would expect that
there's an equal probability
that it could be any number--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Well, a pseudorandom
number generator
would be a function of
program that when I hit Run,
it would output one
of those numbers.
And if I did that
100 times over,
we'd expect on average that
about each number would show up
10 times.
That's what we're saying
with pseudorandom numbers.
But also on top of
that, obviously, there
shouldn't be any clear
identifiable pattern.
It shouldn't be that the
first 10 numbers are 1,
the second 10 numbers are 2,
the third 10 numbers are 3.
And actually, by
definition, if it's true
or if it's a good
random number generator,
it could also generate all ones.
That is possible in randomness.
We obviously don't
want that usually.
But either way, that's the idea.
That's why we only see
pseudorandom number generator
because they're not
truly random numbers.
But either way, we take
those pseudorandom numbers,
and then we have some
key generation program.
Most of these public key
cryptography techniques
use this basic workflow.
It generate some
random numbers, use
those random numbers to generate
a public key and a private key.
And then the idea is that
the public key, it's not,
again, explicitly
visible to everybody.
We don't want it to be
blasted out on the internet.
But the idea is that relevant
access individuals or programs
can use the public key.
If I go on to AWS right
now and into each of you
guys's user accounts, I can see
your individual public keys.
And so if I needed to
encrypt a message to you,
I could use your public key to
encrypt that secret message.
And then in transit, if anybody
were to intercept that message,
they would just see nonsense,
just some random number
or letter combinations.
It could be anything-- symbols.
But then the important
thing is that when
it goes into the
decryption program
on your side of the computer,
you have that secret key.
So the decryption program
is going to basically say,
OK, here's the message,
here's that secret key coming
from the side as well, too.
And that together
can then output
the original secret message.
And the important
thing, too, is I,
even as the one who
generated the secret message
and encrypted it
using your public key,
I can't decrypt this now.
Obviously, I might know what
the original message is,
but I still couldn't
decrypt this.
Only you can do this.
And so that's where we
refer to this server side,
client side is that it should
be encrypted on the server
side, so the server should
handle the encryption,
and that decryption
should really only
happen on your client side
or whatever the client is.
It could be that it's
your EC2 instance.
your local machine.
But that's the idea is
there's this separation.
And so in transit, when
it's not on the server
and it's not on the
client, it's just nonsense.
You cannot see it.
You cannot decrypt it.
RSA encryption, you've probably
noticed is the one we've used.
So every time you go through
that EC2 process or spin-up
process and you create your
new secret key or key pair,
it lets you choose
between RSA or Ed255519.
Both are, again,
doing similar things.
RSA is somewhat agnostic
to the platform,
to the operating system, which
is why I've been using it.
But this is roughly
how RSA works.
And you can imagine a similar
process for the others as well.
So what it does is
it starts by creating
a public key that's just based
on two very large prime numbers.
We can just pick any two
random prime numbers.
I mean, you know what
the prime numbers
are-- something that is only
divisible by 1 and itself.
And so we can just find
two really large numbers.
We're pretty good at iteratively
going through and finding
if something is prime or not.
And so eventually, we'll find
two very large prime numbers,
let's say.
And once we have those
two prime numbers,
we can use those along
with some auxiliary value
and use those in the
RSA encryption program,
in this key generation program.
So input is two
large prime numbers.
In this step, we do
something along the lines
of multiplying them.
And then that outputs
a really large number.
That's the idea.
So imagine if you
take something that's
10 million times 150 million
or something like that,
you're going to get some really
big order of magnitude number.
And so the idea is
then your public key
is that really,
really big number--
the product of those
two large prime numbers.
And so that public key can be
used to encrypt the information.
But the decryption
can only happen
or it depends on basically
being able to factor
those prime numbers or the
large number into the two
original large prime numbers.
So it takes that
really big number,
let's say, the extra large
public key number and needs
to factorize that into the two
large prime numbers that make up
that multiplication.
And there's no guarantee that--
or actually by construction,
that larger number is not prime.
So it could have a lot
of different factors.
And so this is the
idea, if you remember
factorization is this process
of iteratively breaking down
what two numbers can
be multiplied together
to produce the output number.
And so now if we have
to find just only
these two very large
prime numbers that
happen to be factors of this
even larger public key number
is very, very difficult.
You could technically
iteratively try to solve it.
You could just iteratively
try a bunch of numbers
and say, OK, well,
what's 1 times 1?
What's 1 times 2?
What's 2 times 1?
And just keep going through
that iterative process
until you hopefully
find-- you just check
every single pair
of prime numbers
until you get to the solution.
But you'll see if you look
through some documentation
on that or you can look at
the RSA Wikipedia page there--
I'm sure they have
information on that--
but you'll see that process
would take prohibitively long
on modern computers.
Modern architecture
just doesn't have it,
and we don't seem to have any
efficient search algorithms.
But that is technically
the vulnerability
is if you can somehow
crack that process,
if you can factorize into two
large prime numbers efficiently,
you actually can
crack a lot of things.
You can crack most of modern
security systems, web security
systems.
You'd be able to potentially
decrypt sensitive information.
And so that is
something that's known.
And again, as of right now,
our algorithms and our hardware
don't seem to be capable of
doing it in any human lifetime
or time scale.
Quantum computers,
though, which is something
I'm hoping we get to by
the end of the semester,
are a new approach to computing.
They drop the 1-0 computing
idea and utilize some effects
of quantum mechanics, the
superposition of states to allow
for more state representations.
But the big thing here
is it's not really
that we'd be able to
have different computers
that we-- different
MacBooks that are
based on quantum technologies or
quantum computing technologies.
It's more that
these very special
built-- purpose-built
machines would
be very efficient at
that search problem.
Theoretically speaking,
they should be able to do it
once they get to somewhat
of a reasonable size
in a realistic time
scale as well, too.
And so there is
actually very active
research and discussion
going on what
do we do when that time
comes, if that time comes.
Do we have something
that we're prepared for?
And so this is this idea of
recognizing that there exists
vulnerabilities, and
we're going to have
to address them at some point.
Every security system
has vulnerabilities.
It's just knowing what
those are and knowing
if that is sufficient for
the data that you have there.
As of right now, RSA
encryption is sufficient,
but we have to be aware
that it could at some point
not be sufficient
and what can we do
and what strategies are
there to mitigate this.
So ignoring that big existential
doom and gloom statement,
let's take RSA as
working for now.
For our purposes, it's going
to be fine for probably
the next decades.
But either way, don't
quote me on that.
I don't want to go down
in history as saying that.
But either way, AWS has
a key management service
and that's what we've
been using in the back end
and that manages the secret keys
for your users in the account
that you have.
So we can manage all that really
efficiently and automatically.
You don't have to handle the key
generation process and all that.
As you saw, it does it for us.
The important thing,
though, is the private key
can only be accessed once.
So when you create
your key pair,
it's always important that
you download that private key
on the spot and make
sure you keep it.
Once you lose it,
you've lost it.
So if you spin up
an EC2 instance
with a specific key
pair, you do a bunch
of really important
stuff on it, and then
all of a sudden, you
lose that private key,
I'll say it's
possible, potentially,
to get that information back
and recover that instance.
But for the most
part, you're probably
lost that access
to that instance
and potentially that data.
So being very smart about how
you handle that is important.
So yeah, make sure
you store that--
download that, but then
also store it securely.
And we'll talk about that
here in a little bit.
But it's important to make sure
that your computer is never
left unattended because that
private key will give people
access to your AWS account.
You can also encrypt data stored
in really any service that's
supported by KMS,
which is basically
all the standard ones
as I mentioned there,
S3, EBS, EFS RDS.
I think there's
even some more, too.
But those four really
cover most of the things.
We haven't talked about RDS.
That's the relational database
storage system on AWS.
But it's basically everything
is covered by that.
So you can encrypt
data that's stored.
And you can also
encrypt data in transit.
So there's this encrypt
data that's stationary
and then encrypting
data as it's moving.
And so the data in transit
is a bit different.
We won't dive too much into it.
You should take a
network security class
if you really want to
understand this thoroughly.
But this is actually this
idea of security certificates.
You might even have
seen notifications
that certain certificate
is out of date
when you try to access
a website and doesn't
allow you to go there.
This is what's happening
on the back end.
This is HTTPS, the
secure HTTP that
is using or trying to
create the secure tunnel
for the bidirectional
exchange of data.
So the idea, again,
that being that nobody
can inject themselves in the
middle and potentially intercept
information unknowingly.
And so now I want to talk
about how some of these things
appear in real life, some of the
common cloud vulnerabilities.
And hopefully,
again, get you really
excited about just
security, that network
security and computer security
because it's such a fun topic.
So probably the most
common, you might have even
heard of it now--
by now, is the most
common vulnerability
or if you want to phrase
it another way, attack--
this is really an attack on
a network or on a system--
and it's referred to as DDoS.
It stands for distributed
denial of service attack.
So that's what the DDoS is.
And this is basically where
perpetrators just flood a server
with internet traffic.
So imagine you want to--
you're scared your
grades are really bad
and you want professors to
not be able to submit grades
at the end of the
semester, well, then
you could write up
a script to spin up
a bunch of virtual machines
to all of a sudden fire just
requests, just literally
just trying to connect or log
in to USU's website.
And that'll just
take down the system
or log into Banner or
something like that.
And it's just a bunch of
requests to the USU Banner
website, so much so
that eventually, it
just clogs the system.
Because if you think about it,
what a website actually is--
and we'll talk
about this probably
in the next lecture or two--
is a computer that's sitting
somewhere, a server--
but really, let's
just say a computer
that has the website
file sitting there,
the file that holds all the code
and the logic for that website.
That's all a website is.
And then it has
some connections,
some open connections so
users can make requests.
So I can say, hey, I want
to open aws.amazon.com.
And that request goes
out to Amazon's computer.
And Amazon's computer says, here
you go, here's the website back.
So it's this exchange of
information-- a request
and then response from them.
Well, computers have
finite capacity.
There's not an infinite
computer anywhere.
AWS seems like it sometimes.
But given a large
enough attack, it
can be under threat,
too, or even just
in a single availability zone,
for example, or a data center.
But you imagine now that
if all of a sudden I
send so many requests that
it just can't take any more
requests, it's physically
just bogged down
by constant requests,
requests, requests.
So it's getting requests,
it's responding.
It's getting requests,
Eventually a real user is
like, hey, I actually want
to access aws.amazon.com.
They go to make a request,
but there are so many requests
clogging up their inbox, if you
want to think about it that way,
that their request
doesn't really get in
or it's super delayed, and
so the website slows down.
And that can happen.
And that's really
what a DDoS attack is.
And so it's a really
simple, effective one
because outside of stopping
traffic from coming in,
it just looks like your
website is getting popular.
And funny enough,
that can happen.
It can be unintentional.
If any of you guys are
scroll Reddit often,
it's sometimes referred to
as the Reddit hug of death.
Let's say a popular page
website gets accessed or gets
posted on Reddit and it
goes to the front page.
And all of a sudden, everybody's
like, hey, this is really cool.
But it was just your
personal website
where you did some cool
analytics project or something.
And now all of a sudden,
everybody's hitting it,
but it was just hosted
on a single EC2 instance
with 4 gigabytes of
RAM and two cores,
and it just instantly
bogs down your website.
So it's a good thing.
It's actually real people trying
to honestly see your content,
but it's too much for
your server to handle,
and therefore it shuts you down.
Here was an actual post from--
I forget exactly what--
oh, yeah, down here,
if you follow this link,
you can read about it.
But this was a
website where somebody
had made that got, again, on
Reddit, got really popular.
And you can see basically
the hour of the day
here on this horizontal axis.
Their link was posted around
8:00 AM on this first day.
By 12 or yeah, just a
little bit after noon,
the bandwidth per
hour, so the gigabytes
per hour that were being
transferred basically
was over 40 gigabytes.
And that just stayed really
high like this-- server requests
per hour.
They went from having
effectively no service requests
on their website that was likely
live here before to having
almost 600,000 requests in about
four or five hours or actually
it was closer to
eight hours here.
But either way, in the
span of eight hours,
they went up to 600,000
requests from basically nothing.
And so they likely didn't
have their computers,
their servers ready for this.
And so that will shut
down your website
or at least make
it inaccessible.
And you can actually see
here this fun spike again
when the link was posted on
Hacker News, another website.
So it can happen, but it can
also be intentional, too.
I mean, this was me just
searching DDoS attack on August
3rd, 2022.
And I mean, there were just
countless news stories that
showed up for it of attacks
that were happening that day,
that happened to be roughly
when House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi was visiting Taiwan.
And unsurprisingly,
that was something
that was of great
threat to China
or they viewed it as a
great threat to them.
And so then there was
a lot of DDoS attacks
to shut down Taiwanese
websites and all that stuff.
So these are very common
attacks that take place.
Video game servers,
all that stuff.
There exist tools in
AWS to handle this,
to try to address this
and avoid this issue.
One of them is
called AWS Shield.
The idea really being here that
the task is to predict what
internet traffic
is real traffic,
what is a real request
and what isn't.
If something's not a real
request, then just ignore it.
That's all you have to do is
just pretend it doesn't exist.
Don't respond to it.
And the request will come in,
but you can filter those out
and you'll be good to go.
Your website doesn't
go down at all.
It's a non-trivial task--
correctly identifying if
a request is true or not,
given that this request really
is just some information like IP
address, time of day.
Maybe you have something
where you see well
from one specific IP address.
There are 10,000 requests
coming each second.
Well, that likely tells you
that it's one server that's
just blasting you.
So, OK, maybe you just
block that IP address,
and you just ignore
anything from there.
But if anybody is smart, they'll
use a VPN or some other way
to just change up
their IP address.
And so now they can come from
a bunch of different locations.
Well, OK, maybe I
just don't expect
that this is-- given that this
website hasn't been very heavily
trafficked recently, it probably
shouldn't have this spike
from this far across.
Maybe IP addresses
probably should
be localized because everything
else that this website has had--
or every other IP address
that's accessed this website
has come from within
the United States.
And so maybe if all
of a sudden, I'm
getting hits equally
from around the world,
maybe that's uncommon--
or it's coming
from an area that doesn't
have very many web visits.
So all these things are what's
happening in the back end
to try to automatically detect
anything that looks nefarious.
And obviously, as it
detects these things,
negative or malicious actors
will adapt their techniques.
And so it's a constantly
changing process.
And so having a pre-built tool
like this that you can just
have on your website that's
automatically available,
it's very valuable.
And here you can see
in 2020, they actually
mitigated a record attack
that was requesting
2.3 terabits per second.
Another attack that
you might come across--
we talked about this
one a little bit--
is man-in-the-middle attacks.
The most common way
this is presented
is basically when if you access
over an unencrypted Wi-Fi point.
So imagine if you
were at an airport
and you're trying to connect to
Salt Lake City airport Wi-Fi,
well, somebody creates a fake
Wi-Fi access point that's
just their little local
hotspot that's not encrypted,
it's not locked, you
can access it for free,
and it's called
SLC airport Wi-Fi.
And so it looks real.
You connect to it.
But now at this point, all
of your internet traffic
is going through
their Wi-Fi point
and then out to the internet.
So they've injected
themselves in the middle
of your internet access and
you, technically speaking,
might not know if they
are really in there.
You don't know that there's
a man in the middle.
And so they might just
relay your messages.
They might just send
them on and give you--
so you request facebook.com.
They might send that request
right onto facebook.com,
return the response,
pass it off to you,
and you don't see anything.
But the whole time, they've
just been collecting information
about you-- maybe
your passwords,
your internet activity,
the websites you visit.
And they're collecting all
this data without you knowing
or they could even
be altering it.
You make a request and they make
some change to it along the way.
A good example of
this was Comcast
has been in trouble with this
a few times where they have--
again, they're the
internet service provider.
So your requests are
going through them.
And they were basically
injecting code
into third-party web pages.
The web page is not affiliated
with them or you at all.
And they were showing
their own ads and messages.
They did this when people
were pirating movies.
So if you went to a website that
was known to host pirated films,
they would inject an ad or a pop
up into your browser window that
would say, hey, you shouldn't be
pirating content, it's illegal.
We're going to fine you, X, Y
and Z, which maybe they could
make an argument is OK usage.
But it seems like a little
bit of an abuse of power
of being your internet
service provider
and guaranteeing you free and
unlimited access to the internet
to some extent for them
to inject themselves
in the middle like that.
So that is really what an
example of a man-in-the-middle
attack that maybe wasn't
malicious as it's usually
defined, but it is still
an attack nonetheless
on your network security
because your information is now
vulnerable.
The government of Kazakhstan,
and they're not unique in this,
but they basically tried
to circumvent this or be
really creative with this.
So one of the common ways
that we counteract these
man-in-the-middle attacks
is by having these secure
certificates.
There's a mutually trusted
certificate authority usually.
And that's, again, what allows
those or has those security
certificates that have dates on
them and all this kind of stuff.
And that's really what allows
this HTTPS, this secure internet
connection to go through.
Well, the government
of Kazakhstan
created a root certificate,
which the idea was then
that basically it would--
any internet traffic
from internet
users in Kazakhstan
would use this root certificate
such that they would then--
the government would
be in the middle.
They would basically be able to
access any information that's
transported out of Kazakhstan.
And I think it would
end up being mitigated
by having basically most
external companies and websites
just blocked that
root certificate
and just didn't treat it as a
trusted certificate because it
needs to be mutually
trusted, both the sender
and the receiver.
And so therefore, never the
information never went through.
But this is one of the
ways it can be done.
There exists a certificate
manager in AWS, though, again,
to allow you to
provision, manage,
and deploy these
certificates for use
with your personal
websites and all that.
So you don't have to handle
the actual back-end logic
of making sure this
trusted exchange happens.
You just set this up on your end
and AWS will manage the rest.
So again, that's the idea behind
these man-in-the-middle attacks.
Now, unfortunately, there exists
the most common technique.
And this one cannot be mitigated
by AWS or any other cloud
service provider.
They obviously won't talk to
you about a ton about this
because there is no solution
to it-- but social engineering
attacks.
These are attacks where
somebody comes in and basically
tries to convince you
or some other person
to intentionally or
unintentionally share
sensitive information
that can be used
to access a protected system.
So the idea here
is that OK, well--
or you have an example there.
I received a call a couple
of weeks ago, actually.
This bottom bullet point here.
I received a call
a few weeks ago
that was claiming to be an agent
from the Department of Justice
that the first thing they
said to me was basically,
Adrian from the
Department of Justice,
I need you to verify
your name and birth date.
And there, immediately
red flags should go off.
Nobody should be calling you
to ask for any personally
identifiable information.
PII is the abbreviation
that we use for that.
You can see if I
duck out of the way--
PII, Personally
Identifiable Information.
And so the second they asked
for that, your statement should
be absolutely not, I'm
not going to give you
any information when you
were the one that called me.
AWS, for example, it's
never going to contact you.
No cloud provider will ever
contact you and say, hey,
give me your age, name, birth
date, mother's maiden name,
Social Security or the last
four of your Social Security,
anything like that.
Never give it to
somebody that called you.
You can always say thank you.
I will pull that information up.
Hang up the phone, and call back
the numbers that are trusted.
So call back the help or
support number for AWS,
for your bank, whatever it is.
I ended up staying
on the line with them
because I can't
resist a scammer.
It's too fun to talk to them.
But basically, I was then
threatened with legal action
to that if I don't provide my
birth date to identify myself,
then they were going to sue me.
At which point, that's fine.
You let them sue
you because there's
nobody that's allowed
to solicit information,
sensitive information
from you like that,
even though birth date is
something that probably
easily find for me online.
That's not the point.
No matter what the content
is, no matter what it is,
they're going to use that
or can be used because.
Now, let's say, I
provide my birth date.
Well, that's not an uncommon
technique or pattern
to use in passwords.
So now, if they're trying
to crack my passwords
or identify one of
my passwords, they
can try all kinds of
combinations of my age and birth
date.
So that's why they
want that information.
Or that may be something that
they then use to say, OK, great,
now I know his birth date.
Maybe I'll use some
different technique
to acquire, again, some extra
little bit of information.
And slowly, they can
form some profile of me.
And then eventually, they can
call my bank and say, hey,
I forgot my password
to my bank account.
I can't believe this.
I've seen one where they used a
YouTube video of a baby crying
in the background to
pretend like they're just
trying to quickly get access
to a husband or a wife's bank
account.
And the baby's crying.
I just need this
number real quick.
Here's my age and birth date or
here's my husband's birth date
and name and place of birth and
first model of car or whatever.
And then once they
have that, they
can get that actual
sensory information.
And they can say,
actually, can you
change the email
address that gets
sent to you to this email
address, the password reset
link, because I don't have
access to his other email
address?
And now all of a sudden they've
gained access to your account,
and they can do this.
And this is a much more
effective technique
than any coding or
hacking or anything
like that you've seen before.
So that's the one
to worry about.
You can see here this is
a really famous one where
some people actually
ended up getting
an admin password for
a Twitter support staff
or something like that.
And with that admin
password, they
were basically able
to go in and access
every single famous
celebrity's Twitter account.
And they posted this
link to drop money
at their Bitcoin address.
And they would multiply
the money for them
and send them back money.
And obviously, it's a scam.
But unfortunately,
people fell for it
and did send money out to
these Bitcoin addresses
and lost that money.
So be mindful.
People are always trying
to steal your information
and try to protect
as much as you can.
If you want a good book
about it, Ghost In The Wires
is by this guy, Kevin Mitnick.
It's a bit old now.
I mean, it was back in
the days of landlines.
But the techniques
aren't too far
off of what's still used today.
So he was a famous--
I forget what they
exactly called them,
but they would get all these
secret like phone numbers
and passcodes to
access phone records
and have unlimited
international calls when
that used to cost money
and all that stuff.
So it was all social
engineering techniques.
And inevitably, you get
caught and you go to jail.
But there's still people that
are going to keep doing it.
So either way, this is
probably the biggest risk.
And this is one that cannot be
mitigated by any built-in tools.
So all of that being
said, it's very important
even with you guys
having access now
to AWS accounts that come
through our departmental AWS
organization.
You could potentially
leak information.
And if, for example, that's
one of the reasons why
we have to be very intentional
with our IAM privileges.
Because if we just give you
blanket access to everything,
and for whatever
reason, somebody
steals your laptop
from the library
and now they have access
to your private key
and you have your password
saved into your password manager
on Google Chrome, so the second
you log in or you open up AWS,
you can just hit Enter
to connect to AWS,
and now they have
your private key.
Hopefully, you have multi-factor
authentication set up,
and maybe that's one
more blocker of not
being able to access that.
But if they can get
in, then at that point,
they could do anything
they want with the account.
So, again, a lot
of doom and gloom.
So yeah, like I said,
mitigation strategies for that,
for the social engineering tax.
Get that multi-factor
authentication on your AWS
account and all your accounts.
Anywhere you can have
multi-factor authentication,
use it.
It's a slight annoyance.
I know I hate it,
too, but it's just
an app on your phone or
a little key, USB key
that you might have.
And it really does add that
extra really specific layer
of security.
Because now I have to lose
multiple devices and all that
to give anybody access to it.
Store that private key securely.
Don't leave your
computer unattended.
Don't provide any personally
identifiable information
via phone, email,
anything like that.
Never do that.
And consider what information
you share publicly.
Again, security clearances
are a really important one
to think about.
I have had a security
clearance, a top-secret security
clearance for my last job.
And you probably won't
see that anywhere
online that I listed that
because as tempting as it is,
it's actually a
really good point
to post to recruiters
because then you're
eligible for all kinds of jobs
that have that same security
requirements.
So you don't have to go
through that process again.
So it could be a
selling point to you
to have that on your
LinkedIn profile.
At the same point, though,
or at the same time,
you could be putting
a target on your back
because now they
know that, hey, this
is somebody who might have
access to sensitive information.
And so now, all of
a sudden, you're
going to get hit with
a lot of information,
a lot of phishing attempts.
Even the second I
joined the company
and posted that information
on LinkedIn, I immediately--
I mean, it couldn't
have been the next day
I started getting phishing
attempts from sources
that I had never seen before.
So everything you
put out online is
going to be information
for you to use.
And so it's not to say
you hide that information.
Those platforms are great.
I use LinkedIn on a daily basis.
You probably see me on there.
But it's always important
to consider that and be
mindful of what information
is out there about you.
And also try to avoid sharing
what shouldn't be shared.
So keep that in mind.
And also along that line of
security clearances, too.
It might even be something
along the lines of your job.
If you end up in
a director level
position of security at X,
Y, and Z big tech company,
that could be it.
Whether you're a director or
an intern, for that matter,
they know that you might
have access to something.
So all that stuff
is always going
to put a target on your back.
Sorry.
And so that brings you to
this data ethics discussion.
It goes hand in hand with
this idea of security
because we now need
to think about, well,
as users of cloud
platforms, let's say,
you're making a website
and you have logins now.
You now hold somebody's
sensitive information.
If you are a website,
again, that has a login page
and you're managing
the logins yourself,
remember that the vast
majority of people
use the same password
across most platforms.
So if you leak that
information in some way,
whether intentionally
or unintentionally,
you've now put that person at
risk across every platform.
And while that they probably
shouldn't do that, they did.
And so that's still
something to consider.
You have to be mindful of that.
And it goes across the board.
And so there's some good points
here that I found online.
This is a great
article on data ethics.
And so I just wanted to
highlight some of these points.
And so you think about
that as you build tools
and as you start to
utilize the cloud,
you should always remember
that an individual
has ownership over their
own personal information.
It's the same principle
of least privilege.
You need to get
consent or you should
be getting consent for every bit
of data you collect from a user.
So you see how sometimes you
get that prompt of like, hey,
should I allow access
to my microphone
or allow access to my location.
These things should be done, and
it should always be an opt in,
not an opt out.
Their data needs to be
transparent in the sense
that not that everybody
can see their data,
but more that they know
what data you have on them
and how you plan to use that
data, how you collect it,
how you store it,
and how you use it.
That should be available
in some capacity to users.
And maybe that's
something where, again, it
needs to be individual
requests to avoid
posting a bunch of information
about your security systems
online.
But these are things you have to
think about when you're building
a fair and equitable website.
And obviously, data
needs to be private.
We've talked about this
ad nauseam at this point.
But keeping data
private and secure,
you need to be intentional
with the data collection.
You need to ask why you
need the data before you
start collecting it.
Ask why you need
that data point,
what you're going
to gain from it,
and what changes you plan to
make after you analyze the data.
All that needs to be
considered in advance
of collecting that data.
You should never
just start collecting
data blindly and then
assume that at some point
you might use it, you might
not, because you never
know what could be
critical information.
And then finally, consider
the outcomes of that.
What is a potential byproduct
of what you're building
and what you're using?
You won't think of everything,
but try to think of some things.
Try to think of, is
this going to have
some disparate impact on
groups, on specific groups
or individuals?
If it does, you are
starting to potentially
broach into civil
rights act areas,
and those are, again, going to
be unlawful choices to make.
And so, again, taking
all that into account,
considering the outcomes
and how that data might
impact someone or some group
is absolutely critical.
And so I have some
questions there.
This is going to be on
the discussion board.
I want you to think about how
do these five principles really
impact the
considerations that need
to be made in implementing
cloud resources at a company
or an organization.
So think on that.
Read this article that's linked
here right behind my back.
And hopefully, that'll
give you some just food
for thought on not just how
you should be using this,
but also how the platforms and
services you use think about it.
Do they think about your data?
Are they considering
the outcomes?
the intention?
Is it transparent?
Can I go and download it?
If I go on to google.com--
I think it's Takeout
is their platform.
I can go and download every bit
of data that they've claimed
to have collected on me.
And at some point, you have
to take them at their word.
But to some extent,
you're at least
able to see most of what they
could be collecting on you.
And then consider then how do
I adjust my platform's usage.
Is this appropriate?
Do I want this
information out there?
There's a lot of great
services that are benefited
by having access to this data.
Being a data scientist
myself, I love
when I have access
to a lot of data
because it makes my
job a lot easier,
but that doesn't
absolve us of not
being able to be considerate
of how it's being used.
So I think that's
all I have for today.
I'll leave it at that.
There was some good doom
and gloom in this lecture.
I love good doom
and gloom lecture.
But hopefully, it's
at least starting
to get guys thinking about this.
These are really
interesting topics.
And if something's interesting
like this and this impactful,
you can imagine it can
be a great career choice.
So I hope this is something
you pursue further.
If it is, if it's something
you want to look at,
reach out to me.
We've got a couple
courses in our department,
even on network and
internet security.
And we can go from there.
So hope you enjoyed
this lecture.
And I will catch you next time.
Bye.